foreign
last week I gave a fire safety talk
and nobody paid any attention
it's my own fault for using PowerPoint
PowerPoint is boring
people learn in lots of different ways
experience is the best teacher
today
smoking is going to save lives
okay
does anyone smell anything smoky
did you bring your jerky in again
oh my goodness what's the procedure what
do we do people oh how did that happen
it's out in the hall no we don't know
that the smoke could be coming through
an air duct oh my God okay it's
happening everybody stay calm what's up
everyone what's the procedure
calm down no no Michael no touch the
handle if it's hot there could be a fire
in the hallway
[Music]
things can be replaced Phyllis people
human lives however can
ah my hand that's hot this one's hot too
okay we're trapped everyone for himself
have you ever seen a burn victim okay
a rag a damp rag perhaps let's remember
those procedures
that's a wrong way we've already tried
that remember your exit points exit
points people what's next
I'm getting help pull me up you're too
heavy I only weigh 82 pounds
[Music]
how about 9-1-1 anyone 9-1-1
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay I am not dying come on
the fire's shooting at us
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
attention
employees of Thunder Mifflin this has
been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training exercise
so what have we learned
oh come on it's not real family no no no
no no no you will not die Stanley
Stanley you will not die Stanley Stanley
peraki's president you are black sadly I
want to give him a mouth about no no
don't give a mouth to mouth for this
one don't follow him